Spending one day at my sister-in-law's who smokes at her house caused my cancer to get worse.
Normally I'd say no, but the truth is that anything that can just really, you know, smoking
has benzines in the smoke, it has all sorts of other negative things in the smoke.
Very high oxidation rate of cigarette smoke, if you're dealing with detoxification pathways
already, could it cause a flare-up because it's going to cause inflammation possibly,
especially if you have antibodies to benzine, which isn't that uncommon.
So you could look at what's called a Syrex Array 5, and that will give you that will show
that's an antibody test. It will show if you have antibodies to cigarette smoke.
I can't wait till they add antibodies to mRNA viruses into that test, hopefully.
Maybe they never will just for a medical legal reasons, but I do know that we've had people that
went and visited people that were vaccinated, and their cancer got worse noticeably
because they had a visible lymphoma, and it got worse.
We've had lots of people that got vaccinated, and their cancer was in remission, and their cancer
just took off, and they passed away.
So I do know that exposure to chemicals and exposure to things that cause inflammatory processes
and cell damage and oxidation can cause a cancer to grow.
Years ago, I would have said no, but now we're just experiencing that more and more.
So I'd say yes.